سوق السمبوسه سوق الرمضاني شهير في مدينه
ابها ياتي في كل عام مره واحده في شهر
رمضان المبارك امتد عمر هذا السوق لاكثر
من 30 عاما حيث يوجد في حديقه المشهد وقد
تنقل هذا السوق لاكثر من موقع في المنطقه
حقيقتنا اجواء مميزه وهي فرصه للاسر
المنتجه لعرض ما لديهم ايضا فرصه للقهاء
الاحبه والاصدقاء في هذا السوق ونشكر
امانه منطقه عسير على اعاده هذا السوق
يعني الناس افتقدوه فتره طويله ولكن الان
الحمد لله اصبحت يعني شيء مميز
والله يا جواهر رمضانيه صراحه جميله جدا
وفيها اختلاف ثقافات من ناحيه الاكل ومن
ناحيه
الموروث الشعبي اللي
تتميز في منطقه ابها ومنطقه عسير بشكل عام
سكان المنطقه على الذهاب الى سوق السمبوسه
لقضاء جميع احتياجاتهم الرمضانيه بالاضافه
لانه اصبح مكانا للالتقاء بالاهالي
والاصدقاء لتسوق معا والتجول في انحاء
السوق طبعا سوق السمبوسه متواجد منذ سنوات
طويله
كالمعتاد يعني الباعه صار منتجه طبعا في
اللي الناس اللي يتمشون يقضي العصريه وفي
الناس اللي ياخذون لهم فطور على طبعا
اليوم جاي والله اخذ فطور ولا في العاده
والله جيت اتمشى بس وامشي
سوق السمبوسه من الاسواق اللي شي روتيني
او شي اساسي في رمضان في ابها
الحمد لله تقدر الحين تسمع باي واحد تحصله
السمبوسه مو شرط الهدف التسوق او
انك تشتري شيء او شيء يعني شيء روتيني
بتحصل ناس عنهم من عشرات السنوات
اقبلهم كبير يشهدون سوق السمبوسه من
المتسوقين منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك
حيث يرتد السوق المئات بشكل يومي لشراء ما
يناسبهم من الماكولات والمشروبات
الرمضانيه بمسائل عربيه محمد خالد ابها